[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 78 lactu
sur TVfil 78 le point sur l'information
locale de Saint-Quentin en Eveline à
Versailles nous sommes le 23 mai voici
les titres manifestation nationale à
Paris samedi après-midi des élus qui
s'opposent à la réforme des rythmes
scolaires se réuniront avec les parents
et représentant du monde de l'éducation
le Ministre Benoît amont n'entend pas
céder l'apprentissage des enfants il en
sera justement question la semaine
prochaine à an en Yveline avec un
congrès national des conseillers
pédagogiques l'une des organisatrices de
ce rendez-vous sera en plateau pour en
parler et puis toujours en partenariat
avec Radio sensation nous irons à Cannes
pour suivre les ivelinois sur la
Croisette le réalisateur originaire de
Saint-Quentin et Jean carenard y
présente un nouveau longmétrage et puis
comme chaque vendredi en seconde partie
du journal nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
les essentiel de la semaine écoulée
l'image du jour l'image de ce vendredi
c'est la star de télééalité américaine
kim Kardashian et le rppeur Kainy West
attendu à Versailles dans la soirée une
visite privée du château danst la
direction on n d'ailleurs pas souhaité
nous en dire plus et prévu avant que le
couple ne se rende à priori en Touren ou
même à louvciienne toujours dans les
ivblines pour célébrer son mariage même
si l'Italie revient le plus souvent dans
les rumeur cette visite privée du
château de Versailles pour eux et pour
leurs proches est d'ailleurs un lot de
consolation car c'est bien le le palais
du Roi Soleil qui était leur premier
choix pour cette cérémonie la présidente
du château de Versailles Catherine
Pégard a cependant fait savoir que ce
lieu n'était pas dédié à ce genre
d'événement mobilisation nationale cont
les nouveaux rythmes scolaires ce
weekend samedi à 15h un cortège d'élus
de représentants du monde éducatif ou
tout simplement de parents marcheront en
direction du ministère de l'Éducation il
demande l'annulation de la réforme une
table ronde sur l'école de demain on
écoute le maire d'élancours l'UMP
Jean-Michel Fourgous porte-parole de ce
mouvement on n jamais vu des une telle
tension entre entre les maires et et
l'État qu'est-ce que c'est que ces
rapports ou ces pan fafess une réforme
comme ça elle doit être partagée elle
doit être concertée elle doit être
acceptée enfin les les profes vous allez
pas comme ça les
forcer non mais c'est fini c'est pas un
régime autoritaire une démocratie on est
sérieux on fait pas de politique des
maires de gauche des maires de droite
des maires du champ des Maes qui sont
absolument pas engagé d'ailleurs qui
disent que cette réforme est une
mauvaise réforme contre l'intérêt de
l'enfant et incohérente àis des des
baisses de dotations qu'on qu'on vient
de recevoir on voit pas comment on peut
financer une telle réforme qui ne sert à
rien de son côté Benoît amont le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
rappelle une règle simple c'est l'État
et non les communes qui fixent le temps
scolaire au villees revient
l'organisation du temps périscolaire
donc la réforme s'appliquera il ne peut
pas en être autrement des propos
recueillis du ministre en marge de la
remise du prix du Trophée culture et
diversité d'improvisation à Paris ça va
s'appliquer partout c'est pas il y a une
confusion qui laisse à penser que
l'organisation du temps scolaire est
fixée par les maires c'est l'État qui
les fixe et il relève il revient au mare
de d'organiser le temps autour de
l'école le temps périscolaire mais nous
ce que nous avons voulu c'est que les
gamins les enfants pardon en primaire
apprennent mieux en apprenant davantage
le matin et donc une matinée de plus
pour ça que nous avons arrêté comme
principe cinq matinées de dans le temps
scolaire pas forcément successif ça peut
être le samedi matin ou le mercredi
matin nos enfants est mieux le niveau
des écoles était meilleur quand on avait
5 matinées c'est pour ça qu'on veut y
revenir et aussi parce que les parents
doivent le savoir leurs enfants sont
mieux concentrés entre 9h et 11h du
matin et quand on rajoute un matin ben
ça leur donnera davantage de chance de
maîtriser le français et les
mathématique or ce sont sur ces
apprentissages fondamentaux que l'école
française aujourd'hui recule donc on va
avancer à la rentrée prochaine
l'organisation du temps scolaire elle
sera arrêtée en fonction de ces
principes là que nous avons voulu
travailler avec les maires c'est la
première fois
gouvernement invite les maires à
travailler c'est à penser le pé scolaire
autour du temps scolaire mais ce que
d'abord un parent demande au ministre de
l'éducation et au professeur ou un
directeur d'école c'est que son garçon
ou sa fille apprennent correctement le
français ou les mathématiques c'est
l'engagement que nous prenons avec cette
réforme des rythmes scolaires et puis
autour on va travailler avec les maires
les rythmes périscolaire j'entends des
ma dire on ne l'appliquera pas sachez
qu'ils n'ont pas le pouvoir de ne pas
l'appliquer moi j'ai proposé des
assouplissements pour tenir compte de la
vie des maires mais je vais pas remettre
en cause le principeune réforme qui est
favorable aux apprentissages au motif
que certains maires n'y arrivent pas
mais je rappelle que ces maires qui
disent de pas vouloir organiser la
réforme ils ontie de dire que qu'ils le
veuillent ou pas et qu'il qu'il donne un
contenu au périscolaire c'est-à-dire
qu'ils organisent des activités ou pas
l'engagement de l'État c'est de leur
verser de toute façon 50 € par enfant
donc il faudra que ses maères tous
disent que font Onil de 50 € par enfant
alors qu'il n'organise rien dans les
activités pérécolaires et moi je leur
demande que ferez-vous de ces 50 € et
moi je regrette que aujourd'hui des
maires préfèrent appliquer la consigne
d'un bure du bureau national de
l'UMP sur la réforme des rythmes que de
se mettre autour d'une table là où
notamment dans le décret
d'assouplissement j'ai montré la volonté
du gouvernement de tenir compte de ce
qu'on nous disait sur le terrain de la
différence entre l'école maternelle et
l'école primaire tout ça on en a tenu
compte ça ne relève plus de moi ça
relève de Monsieur P je demande d'être
un peu plus raisonnable malgré le ton
ferme du ministre les déclarations de ma
refusant de mettre en place cette
réforme dès le mois de septembre se
multiplie plaisir morp ou encore bois
d'Arc Philippe benasaya le maire de
cette commune l'a d'ailleurs déclaré sur
notre antenne cette semaine sur la
réforme des rythmes scolaires lorsqu'on
a des convictions il faut les il faut
les appliquer j'étais contre cette
réforme je suis toujours contre cette
réforme je pense qu'elle fatigue les
enfants elle n'est pas financée en plus
et en plus compte tenu des marges de
manœuvre des de notre budget qui sont
totalement nuls euh il est presque il
est totalement impossible de d'appliquer
cette réforme qui va coûter cher alors
soit j'augmente les impôts pour
appliquer cette réforme dont on ne sait
même pas si elle a un impact positif sur
les enfants comme à plaisir commeelle en
cours vous n'appliquerez pas cette
réform je reporte donc pour la rentrée
2014-215 cette réforme des rythmes SCOL
pour autant vous nous dites que vous
reportez mais le responsable de de
l'Académie nous avons rencontré il y a
quelques jours on nous disait qu'il
mettrait en place lui-même la réforme si
les maires ne voulaient pas l'appliquer
il fait les horaires et si les ma ne
veulent toujours pas appliquer les
nouveaux horaires ce sera au préfet et
bien on verra à ce moment-là on verra à
ce moment pourz vous attacher à l'école
com si les préfets demandent à ce que
les écoles soient ouvertes en tout cas
on iront nous irons le plus loin
possible dans nos convictions ensuite on
verra s'il faut discuter parce que cette
méthode là de l'État toutpuissant qui
impose à une commune malgré les marges
de manœuvre nul dont je parle une
réforme dont on a absolument pas des
résultats au niveau des des enfants je
trouve ça intolérable je trouve ça euh
totalitaire pardonnez-moi l'pr pression
voilà manifestation nationale à Paris
samedi après-midi le point complet ce
sera dans notre prochaine édition du
journal lundi à 18h en direct on reste
dans le domaine de l'éducation puisque
je reçois à présent Jacqueline salin
bonjour bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes la présidente dans les
ivelines de l'Association nationale des
conseillers pédagogiques il est question
du Congrès de l'Association nationale
des conseillers pédagogiques du premier
degré qui va se dérouler sur le site de
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
à guillencour de dimanche à mer mercredi
250 formateurs du premier degré de
métropole et des DomTom également seront
seront présents pour débattre de
l'apprentissage de la formation au sein
de l'éducation nationale et forcément au
regard de l'actualité je vais vous poser
cette question est-ce que vous allez
aborder les rythmes scolaires est-ce que
ça fait partie des préoccupation
l'application des rythmes scolaires ça
fait bien sûr partie des de nos
préoccupations puisque c'est la vie de
l'enfant qui
est qui est
cité dans dans ce temps là puisque c'est
le temps de l'enfant
euh les périodes de d'apprentissage
varient effectivement selon le matin le
début de la matinée la fin de la matinée
l'après-midi tout ça peut être très
variable mais nous nous axerons
peut-être plus nos travaux sur comment
on peut faire accéder les enfants à
toute à la réussite scolaire alors quel
est l'objet justement c'est de
d'échanger des des expérience que chacun
puisse se retrouver sur un temps
d'échange et partager tout simplement
alors c'est une c'est un temps de
formation qui placé sous le ha patronage
de Monsieur le Ministre de l'Éducation
nationale un temps de formation qui nous
permet de rencontrer des chercheurs qui
nous permet de rencontrer
des des spécialistes de de
l'apprentissage puisque nous notre thème
cette année donc c'est donc apprendre au
21e siècle la recherche l'innovation les
différentes politiques qui sont mises en
place également
et comment on peut mettre cela en place
place pour la réussite de tous les
élèves ça s'adresse au conseillers
pédagogiques à l'école alors ces
conseillers pédagogiques leur rôle ce
sont les formateurs des enseignants
voilà tout à fait alors les conseillers
pédagogiques essentiellement sur la
formation continue donc une fois que les
les enseignants ont eu le fameux
concours pour
rentrer dans le professeurat des écoles
donc bien du premier degré euh les
conseillers pédagogiques tout d'abord
sont issu également de du professorat
des écoles hein
donc on les accompagne enfin les les
conseillers pédagogiques les
accompagnent dans leur projet dans leur
manière de de faire la classe de
s'adapté aux élèves aux
conditions qui qui sont les leurs dans
puisque chaque chaque école presque a
des conditions tout à fait différentes
et puis que leur
projet propose du sens aux élèves qu'ils
soient qu'ils soient donc très intéressé
par ce qu'on leur propose et non
seulement intéressé mais qu'ils
apprennent est-ce qu'il y a des conseill
pédagogiques qui quelquefois sont sont
perdu ne savent pas répondre aux
demandes des enseignants parce que ça
évolue ça a beaucoup évolué ces
dernières années effectivement ça a
beaucoup évolué et là on est d'ailleurs
sur des dispositifs qui qui se mettent
en place plus de mettre que de classe la
scolarisation des moins de 3 ans le
numérique à l'école c'est vrai que la
formation des enseign des conseillers
pédagogiques était aussi nécessaire et
c'est dans ce cadre là que nous nous
faisons ce congrès et par fois
effectivement il il arrive que nous
avons aussi des inquiétudes ou ù nous ne
pouvons pas je dis toujours on n'est pas
des médecins on n pas la grippe et puis
on va vous donner un médicament pour non
c'est pas possible parce qu'il faut
accompagner c'est beaucoup un travail
d'accompagnement on c'est du cas par cas
à chaque fois forcément en fonction de
l'école de la situation de l'IGN
absolument parce que si c'était juste un
tenter à résoudre non mais toujours
c'est toujours dans un contexte c'est
fréquent ce temps d'échange qui est
organisé est-ce que vous ça revient
régulièrement ENF en tout cas chaque
année pour votre congrès mais est-ce qu'
audelà de ça les conseils pédagogiques
sont sont encadrés aussi au quotidien
tout alors il y a des des temps de
formation qui sont organisés mais qui
sont qui sont vraiment euh très
différents les uns des autres les
structures sont différentes au niveau
des départements au niveau des des
circonscriptions aussi puisquil y a une
trentaine de circonscriptions dans le
département des Yvelines et ça
fonctionne différemment dans differses
circonscriptions mais toujours dans le
même objectif quand même accompagner les
enseignants qui n'ont pas eu de
formation pendant quelques années là il
faut le dire donc la formation continuée
celle qui quand ils étaient sur le
terrain était essentiel concrètement le
programme ça va s'organiser comment des
intervenants des spécialistes ça débute
dimanche jusqu'à mercredi à l'université
de de versailles- SaintQuentin c'est
réservé bien évidemment au personnel du
monde de l'éducation on aura l'occasion
d'en parler en tout cas dans une
prochaine édition de de ce journal mais
sur le programme comment ça va se
dérouler et bien tout d'abord donc nous
allons avoir le lundi trois conférences
avec François tadi qui est chercheur au
qui est
chercheur vous aurez en tout cas aussi
des intervenants locaux parce que je
pense à alin ser par exemple qui est le
le responsable de la maison d'édition
rue du monde voilà puisque la littérat
je voilà la littérature de jeunesse est
très importante puisque le ministre
parlait tout à l'heure de la lecture
effectivementin donc comment quel
support apporter aux classes au maîtres
pour que les élèves prennent conscience
du monde qui les qui les entourent donc
iner en tant que régional on va dire et
plus éditeur et sinon euh Philippe
Merieux grand pédagogue enfin je crois
que vous le connaissez qui qui viendra
euh voir comment qu'est-ce qui est
nécessaire qu'est-ce qui l'utile quel
est l'utile pour les pour les
enseignants pour que des exemples
concrets pour qu'ils puissent répondre à
toutes les demandes voà et le propos euh
c'est essentiellement comment lier la
recherche puisqu'il y a vraiment
beaucoup de de travaux qui sont
effectués euh sur la pédagogie comment
lier ce ce travail de recherche et la
mise en place sur le terrain merci
Jacqueline salin présidente dans les
evvelines de l'Association nationale des
conseillers pédagogiques d'êtreevenu
nous parler de ce congrès qui va
s'ouvrir dimanche je sais que vous êtes
en pleine préparation alors on va vous
laisser y retourner merci encore à vous
le scrutin européen c'est dimanche
également un seul et unique tour pour
désigner nos eurodéputés en dehors de
l'aspect politique de la campagne que
vous pouvez d'ailleurs retrouver sur
notre site Internet à travers reportage
et débats nous vous avons aussi proposé
dans nos différentes éditions des
illustrations conête du rôle de l'Union
dans notre quotidien autre exemple
aujourd'hui avec les entreprises comment
l'Union européenne peut aider les TPE un
sujet signé cler
Cambier nous produisons nos blé en
agriculture raisonnée donc on a une
certification agriculture raisonnée et
donc j'ai décidé de monter une meunerie
sur Meul de Pierre donc écraser mes
propres blés faire ma propre farine qui
est une farine semi-complète et je
travaille avec mes deux fils se
diversifier pour perdurer mais pour cela
rapidement il a fallu investir pour
payer un cabinet d'ingénierie agricole
et du nouveau matériel montant pour
rénover la meunerie 130000 € Marc s'est
alors tourn vers la chambre
d'agriculture ensemble ils ont effectué
une demande de subvention aux
collectivités territorial l'Union
européenne y a répondu favorablement
avec les conseils régional et général
elle lui a accordé une aide à hauteur de
30 % de son investissement l'Union
européenne aide ainsi le milieu agricole
à travers des financements du féader le
Fond Européen agricole pour le dével
rural mais il existe d'autres fonds
structurels avec des budgets plus
conséquents pour les Fonds structurels
il y a deux grands types de fonds en
France le FEDER le Fond Européen de
Développement régional le FSE le Fond
Social Européen c'est sur le même
principe c'est-à-dire une programmation
de 7 ans et les petites entreprises sont
là aussi concernées pour chaque fond
sollicité il faut répondre à un certain
nombre de critères ils peuvent concerner
la taille de l'entreprise ses
partenariats ou encore le type de
secteur au-delà de ces fonds structurel
l'Union européenne aide les PME à
travers des aides directes pour en
bénéficier les entreprises doivent
postuler auprès de la Commission
européenne via des appels à projets et
selon un calendrier défini les
programmes les plus importants
concernent les secteurs de
l'environnement de l'audiovisuel de
l'aide à la formation mais surtout les
projets de recherche et
d'innovation au Jardin de Cocagne à
Manil et à Moot on ne mise pas sur la
recherche et le développement mais sur
l'insertion et l'Union européenne
encourage dans une moindre mesure ce
type d'entreprise ici chaque année 40
personnes éloignées de l'emploi sont
recrutées comme jardinier le but les
former et les aider à retrouver un poste
pérenne on a obtenu 23000 € chaque année
qui correspondait au financement de la
personne qui accompagnait nos jardinier
c'est un dossier très administratif avec
beaucoup de statistiques beaucoup de
demandes liées au projet aussi qui va
être très précis sachant qu'après on
sera jugé sur les résultats par rapport
au projet pour contrer ces difficultés
l'Union européenne a mis en place des
aides non financières indirect qui vont
plutôt être des personnes qui vont les
aider à décrocher ces subventions pour
leurs activités donc là typiquement le
réseau Entreprise Europe pour
l'île-de-fance c'est une trentaine de
personnes qui sont qui sont là pour
accompagner les entreprises enfin
l'Union européenne propose un 4è type
d'aide auprès d'institutions financières
ces intermédiaires proposent alors de
meilleures conditions bancaires comme
par exemple des taux d'emprunt réduits
l'Union européenne vient donc épauler
les entreprises et les petites
structures ont droit à leur part du
gâteau le but est clairement affiché
qu'elle crée de la richesse avec la mise
sur le marché de nouveaux produits ou de
nouveaux services et de l'emploi en
Europe l'Europe ETV dernier épisode pour
notre série réalisée avec Europe Direct
Eveline aujourd'hui les questions
d'internet c'est toujours au micro de
Catherine
zulato le Parlement européen notamment
dans son dernier Paquet Télécom qu'il a
voté a voté ce qu'on appelle la
neutralité du net alors la neutralité du
net c'est un principe un peu politique
assez barbare à comprendre mais c'est
très simple c'est-à-dire que quand vous
accédez à Internet vous avez un net
entier c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
accéder facilement à vos mails surfer
sur Internet accéder à YouTube pour pour
regarder vos vidéos ça c'est la
neutralité du Net le fait de ne pas
avoir de neutralité du net ça permet à
un opérateur tout simplement de
décomposer votre votre votre utilisation
d'internet et vous sur et vous payer et
vous faire payer les utilisations
particulières c'est-à-dire qu'un
opérateur s'il n'y a pas la ne s'il n'y
a pas la neutralité du Net un opérateur
peut vous facturer un coût
supplémentaire pour pouvoir accéder à
vos mails pour pouvoir regarder Youtube
pour pouvoir faire du Skype et ainsi de
suite ça évite de devoir payer sa
facture Internet 80 € voilà donc on
reste sur grâce à cette décision du
Parlement européen on va rester sur les
tarifs actuels à peu près d'une de 20 à
40 € pour une connexion Internet
complète c'est un principe politique
c'est-à-dire que là c'est les opérateurs
qui euh le font de bonne volonté il faut
bien comprendre que si un opérateur se
met à le faire de son côté il va perdre
tous ses clients tous les clients vont
aller vers un autre maintenant c'est une
demande assez récurrente des principaux
opérateurs en France de pouvoir
décomposer de pouvoir décomposer et de
et de facturer les services
supplémentaires parce que tout
simplement les développements des
réseaux internet à grande vitesse ça
demande des des infrastructures de plus
en plus complexes donc ça demande des
investissements de plus en plus lourds
des opérateurs le fait de faire payer en
plus les consommateurs ça permettait
de de de de tout simplement de se de se
rentabiliser le Parlement européen a
imposé un chargeur universel pour tout
ce qui est les smartphones tablettes et
compagnie bon la plupart du temps on a
ce qu'on appelle une conétique micro USB
mais on va pas se cacher pour les
téléphones notamment de la marque Apple
on a toujours un chargeur particulier
alors maintenant le Parlement européen
d'ici 2017 on va av grâce au Parlement
européen on va avoir un chargeur unique
voilà donc c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui
est les tout ce qui est téléphone
tablette on pourra les recharger VI a un
même câble voilà peu importe la marque
du produit peu importe le pays dans
lequel vous vous retrouvez ça sera
toujours le même
câble de l'Europe à Cann dernier volet
également ce soir de notre série
d'interview à CAN en partenariat avec
Radio sensation les iblinois sont aussi
sur la Croisette et notamment Jean
carenard il est né à Port au Prince en
Haïti en 1980 il a ensuite grandi à 50
ans en ivbline sur la Croisette il
présentait son deuxè long FLA faire
l'amour projeté en ouverture de la
Semaine de la Critique en parallèle de
la compétition officielle l'histoire
d'un rappeur atteint de surdité
tirailler entre deux femmes deux sœurs
un film sur le handicap qui invite au
dialogue l'accueil a été plutôt bon de
quoi donner confiance au jeunes
réalisateurs qui a déjà très envie de
repartir en tournage et de mener
d'autres projets notamment un spectacle
le pitch le pitch en fait c'est un c'est
l'histoire d'un d'un rappeur qui est en
train de devenir sourd et et qui est qui
est aussi tiraillé entre deux F
ce que j'ai envie de transmettre aux
spectateurs
c'est c'est
c'est c'est de la difficulté de de la
relation amoureuse déjà et puis ensuite
ensuite de la difficulté aussi du du
handicap autant pour soi que pour son
entourage ben en fait c'est un scénario
que j'avais écrit quand j'habitais
encore dans 78 quand j'habitais quand
j'habitais à Versailles en 2007 et donc
je l'avais écrit à ce moment-là et puis
entreetemps j'ai fait mon premier long
métrage et puis euh et puis en fait ce
scénario là que j'avais écrit avant ben
il a plu et donc voilà après ça s ça
s'est mis sur pied quoi il y a des
partenaires qui ont qui ont suivi et
puis et puis tout s goupillé pas mal de
projets on travaille en écriture en ce
moment là en ce moment aussi bien sur
aussi bien sur du cinéma que sur des
projets théâtraux avec avec Laura euh
bah ouais c'est une continuité donc
effectivement là on est au stade de
l'écriture mais l'idée c'est que ça
s'arrête c'est que l'énergie l'énergie
d'une d'une victoire parce que c'était
un challenge bah serve à à le voilà en
remporter d'autres et du coup entamer
d'autres projet on est en train d'écrire
un spectacle ensemble qui va qui est là
un projet de scène donc tout en
continuant notre route on se diversifie
et on va toujours bah pilepoil dans ce
qu'on veut faire et dans ce qu'on aimeme
le le spectacle
estce vous avez l'exclu le thème
c'est elle réfléchit ce qu'elle peut
dire ce qu'elle peut pas dire ce c'est
trop tôt de
dire ah c'est toi qui t'es lancé hein
tuas dit on va réserver la surprise si
vous revenez TVfil 78 on vous en dira
des pavés ça va être un spectacle
extraordinaire vous en avz avoir plein
les yeux plein la vue plein l'essens
comme d'habitude mais il faudrait être
un peu patient on va être encore un peu
patient alors en tout cas dimanche radio
sensation consacrera une émission
spéciale aux yvelinois présent au
festival de Cann l'occasion de découvrir
les coulisses de cette 67e édition c'est
donc dimanche à partir de 19h dans un
zest d'info avec Nicolas kirilovitz et
Franck
[Musique]
David l'information principale de cette
semaine à présent c'est le blocage des
entrepôts de Febus à Versailles la
société de transport en commun ne peut
plus assurer son service depuis de
semaines en raison d'un vaste mouvement
social la justice a décidé maintenant de
s'emmêler elle a ordonné que les
conditions la mise en place d'un service
minimum soit rempli
jérémybrass ce mercredi au dépôt de fbus
à versaill l'abattement régnait parmi
les grevvistes plus tôt dans la journée
le tribunal a ordonné la fin du blocage
du dépôt David mtin avocat des grevistes
note néanmoins deux irrégularités dans
la décision du tribunal il a fait appel
d'une part il y avait il y a eu un
blocage c'est vrai mais pas un blocage
de l'entreprise et pas un blocage de
l'entrepôt il y a eu un barrage qui a
été fait sur la voie publique les bus
sortaient du dépôt mais ils étaient
bloqués à 50 m du dépôt ça veut dire que
en droit j'insiste en drit on est sur la
voie publique on n'est pas dans
l'entreprise et d'ailleurs les barrières
de la de l'entreprise étaient fermées
par la direction l'autre point ce sont
les les grvistes si ont été assignés on
ne comprend pas pourquoi 220 grevistes
sont expulsés alors que seuls six sont
atés en justice et le tribunal n'a pas
encore déterminer la date de la
prochaine audience ce jeudi la situation
semblait évoluer dans le bon sens
puisque le dialogue s'est établi entre
les représentants de l'intersyndical
greviste et la direction des
négociations ont commencé ce matin le
trafic en revanche n'est toujours pas
revenu à la normale selon les grevistes
environ 15 % des bus seulement seraient
sortis du dépôt contacté à plusieurs
reprise la direction de Febus n'a pas
donné suite à nos sollicitations pour
rappel les grevistes se plaignent de
conditions de travail qu'il jugent
déplorable et réclame une augmentation
salariale de 5
%. pour terminer ce journal et si vous
nous suivez ce vendredi n'oubliez pas ce
soir 23 mai de faire la fête avec vos
voisins la fête des voisins également
baptisé immeuble en fête en temps recréé
du lien social depuis 99 et sa première
édition parisienne vous voyez sur ces
images l'une des éditions qui se'est
déroulé à trappe depuis le concept se
décline à l'international Canada Turquie
les services des mairies peuvent vous
aider pour l'organisation bonne fête
donc à chacun et puis n'oubliez pas tout
de même avant de fêter vos voisins qu'il
faut aussi prévoir de quoi fêter nos
mamans ce sera dimanche prochaine
édition du 78 lactu lundi en direct à
18h nous reviendrons sur les résultats
aux européennes dans le département et
sur cette mobilisation contre les
rythmes scolaires qui ne faiblit pas
nous l'avons vu au début de ce journal
très bon
[Musique]
weekend